right now we're going to turn to uh
another element of this story being
joined by the chief of psychology at
texas children's hospital karen price
she's helping lead a trauma response
team that is going to offer support to
the uvalde community we've heard how
tight of a community it is there karen
good morning to you i think so many
people are wondering
what do you say to those members of the
community and this isn't your first time
dealing with a school shooting like this
that's correct the things that we say to
the community are that we're here to
support you you're our neighbors and we
want to help in any way that we can we
want to mobilize resources to address
any of the needs that the community has
beginning now but also in the long run
as they recover and move on to the next
phase of this tragedy
just hearing in tony's interview there
hearing that young girl who saw her best
friend get shot
how do you help a child start to process
that
right now in this immediate time frame
we don't worry about processing the
trauma we worry about keeping kids safe
we worry about the adults who are around
them the people that care for them and
take care of them getting the help that
they need to be the support that their
parents need to let them know that all
feelings that they have are okay
to keep structure and routine in their
children's lives and to give them the
space to talk about the pieces that they
want to talk about and not push them to
talk about the things they're not ready
to talk about yet
you're heading into uvalde you're going
to the front lines
what's your first order of business when
you actually
meet with the parents and the survivors
our first order of business is to make
sure that they are armed with the
information they need to support their
children the best those are things like
making sure that parents are getting the
support they need to manage their
emotions all emotions are okay in this
situation these families have been
through truly an unspeakable tragedy
but they need to get their help and
support away from their children so that
when they are sitting with their
children when they're laying in bed with
them at night they're there to give the
support and comfort that their child
needs to deal with their own feelings
the story is so big here and i think
it's different when it's children
innocent defenseless children at school
of all places so even people who are
watching this are filled with outrage
filled with grief filled with a lot of
anger too what's the best way to deal
with that as you're watching these
images and listening to these
heartbreaking stories
one of the things that we suggest is
making sure that you have an outlet
whether that is your partner your spouse
a family member a best friend
somebody that you're connected with in
your community to process those feelings
with
the other thing is to make sure that
everybody is also taking care of
themselves we can't help other people
if we are not taking care of ourselves
for people that are really traumatized
by the pictures that they see in the
stories that they hear they may need to
take a break and be really careful about
what they are exposing themselves to and
we also need to be really careful about
what our children are being exposed to
and what can you say about mental health
at this time
you know it seems the conversation is
now moving to this is a mental health
issue we need to do something about
mental health which is also true but
there are a lot of mentally ill people
that don't go and do this isn't this so
much bigger than a mental health issue
mental health is certainly part of the
picture i don't think it's the full
story we know that we have a mental
health crisis in this country and really
in many many countries across the world
in the wake of the covet 19 pandemic
and certainly we need to do our best to
create systems of care to take care of
children adults families
at any stage where they might be
experiencing mental health concerns
i do think that we can talk about as
information comes out how we could make
things different in the future what
signs we need to look for that somebody
might be experiencing
the kind of mental health concerns that
could lead them to be dangerous while
also recognizing that you're right the
vast majority of people with mental
illness are not dangerous they're not a
danger to society well karen we're glad
your team will be there for this
community sorry that you've had this
experience already in order to go serve
them thank you for your time